coming up next oh that's interesting no
because this I don't know you sound
older like you look younger but you
sound older and I maybe it's just
because of what you do I hate to go to
the Embassy and do something you know
that's a scam but I I believe them for
one reason why wyt what
you did me American
because I love
hey they have you have some of the
smartest and the dumbest people in the
world
[Music]
okay hi
hi nice to meet you I'm Alex Alexander
Alex okay nice to meet you
so uh
[Music]
um it's interesting I like to perform
you like to perform yeah is that what
you do like is that like your thing no
I'm in Tech you're in Tech okay what
kind of tech data engineering data
engineering how'd you get into that
um I was as a long story actually I was
a teacher I started out in mechanical
engineering designing buildings so I
helped design like the sky headquarters
in London stuff like that really
um yeah and then that was very boring I
thought the industry was kind of not
very Innovative so I ended up in sales
and I did operations management and then
I was a teacher teaching maths and
physics for a while and then I taught
myself wait wait you taught math and
physics okay so what you need to know
I'm a College Dropout okay I'm like a
creative free spirit so like you're like
the opposite like literally math like I
could barely do math now I have to pull
out a calculator just for a tip like in
a restaurant
over there you don't like quantum
physics or something like that I
wouldn't go that far okay I'm like I'm
like dumb compared to that no I did see
you do some quick math for King so I I
tried but it's like slow math like I
have to like use my fingers I'm like one
two three or five like did you go to
school for it I mean of course you had
to yeah okay like did you have to get
like a master's degree for that like
again you're talking to a Dropout so I'm
not I'm just like I did a bachelor's
um did all right and then kind of
figured my you know worked my way in
work your way in okay how old are you 28
28 okay
oh that's interesting no because this I
don't know you sound older like you look
younger but you sound older and I maybe
it's just because of what you do like
being in math and physics and what got
you interested in that were you always
good at it
um yeah basically
um would they call a report card here
like in school when you get your grades
we call it a report card here we don't
get enough for that we just call it you
just get your grades you just get your
grades did you do they do it like
quarterly like they do in the US or like
every semester how does it work I don't
know how this goes I don't even know
like in University it was like every
semester and then at the end of the year
you were a teacher you don't know you
didn't have to get great I trained I
trained at King's college for teaching
so I was doing that for like six hours
oh so you actually taught at like
college it's wait is college the same as
University here it's a high school
college is considered high school
here does University then there's high
schools before University
okay what is high school what's the ages
of high school it's like a 11 to 18 11
18. okay so then you go to college after
that then it's six yeah then it's
University
wait which one's college is University
for you guys right it's the same thing
University and college yeah yeah so it's
been so long a girl I actually so long
you're 28 you would think that you're
like 108. you've done a lot I think
you've done a lot too I have done a lot
I've I've lived a life so yeah you're
saying you traveled around Italy I did
and I didn't think I would love it as
much as I do I like the Amalfi Coast I
know that sounds stuck up but like I
literally never thought about it but it
was like Sorrento was probably my
favorite place on Earth right now yeah
have you heard of it no I've never been
to Italy it is gorgeous like I think is
the prettiest place I want like I went
to Greece I thought I would like Greece
more like Mykonos and all of that but I
didn't it was Italy is definitely where
it was for me it was good everything was
good the people were nice you like the
Italians
like the Italian people Italian culture
yeah spirited people they they're not as
spirited as as my people back because
that's what they call Spirit we're
spirited back home so and me Americans
what do you guys think of Americans uh
there's a love-hate relationship I feel
they have you have some of the smartest
and the dumbest people in the world
that's what I think I agree okay who who
why do you say the dumbest though
there's just it seems to be like you
know a lot of a bit of a you know a
culture of our degeneracy in some parts
and some in some kind of perspectives
but also you've got you know Steve Jobs
all these massive companies people who
are just really pushing the Frontiers on
so many things it's like both right like
you guys they have that everywhere the
UK you're telling me is not some of the
smartest and dumbest people you have
ever come across yeah but it's a bit
more balanced here like I think yeah
like it's a bit more I think in America
it gets extreme I've seen some just
YouTube give me extreme give me an
extreme I don't know I've seen some
stuff online the way people I meet a lot
of Americans traveling so I backpacked
around Thailand I was just in Mexico so
I meet a lot of Americans and it just
seems like you know when you meet
British people that normally kind of
pass it and you know maybe then from the
north and they're a bit like Rowdy but
Americans are either like really quiet
and obviously affluent or they're just
like yeah but let's go to the strip club
let's do this yeah oh bro I just got
robbed bro I swear I'll pay you back I
mean oh you're just a little scamming
now like that's a whole nother list you
know there's there's levels to this
thing like you're talking about you went
straight to scam or something I'll pay
you back but you know and I'll like the
normal person and well actually is it
one La guy stopped US to Mexico he said
he was robbed and he was talking about
how he had all these like g-star jeans
and and Gucci watches and it's just or
just like as soon as you start throwing
out labels that's it that's a scam
that's a scam oh baby yeah maybe yeah
all this stuff bro if you got all of
that why are you talking to people on
the street like you should have money in
your account to get it back together you
said he got robbed of everything you
finally left everything with some who
did you go to the Embassy and do
something you know that's a scam but I I
believe them for one reason he had very
white teeth
you know we have the like the whitening
strips you can do all types of things
listen if you're really struggling in
Mexico your teeth would not be that like
perfect like that's definitely that is a
lot so good cheese means no scammy
that's that's what I thought I was like
I've never seen a homeless person with
like great a pearly whites but lined up
see homeless doesn't ego scammer though
true you have to be careful like there's
whole channels on YouTube dedicate to
scammers have you seen it no no oh my
gosh you should see it they are like the
best things ever because these guys are
like hackers who actually scam them back
like so they can actually they send them
a link to try to steal their money and
they log in and end up going into their
whole computer system and like killing
the game
that's the positives the smart people in
America what would you like Have You
Ever Seen The Maury Show do you guys
have the equivalent of the memorial no
Maury okay Maury Povich like Mori like
you are the Father the DNA results I'm a
billion percent sure that he is the
father oh shoot
oh I was enjoying life
I was about to give you a whole
Morrisville it's over now sorry this is
nice to meet you pleasure to meet you I
hope you guys talk again soon okay they
say never meet your idol face to face
your idol face to face who's your Idol
oh I'm you're in my eye
she just told me I look uglier I'm
annoying yeah and you're like where are
we going you know it's a tough space
yeah this conversation oh wow okay